hello everyone and welcome to the first
leg of the fide grand prix that is
currently being played in berlin uh this
is the first game that we are going to
show a lot of you guys have already
requested as vincent kymer versus daniel
dubov uh it's uh really really a
complicated game and features uh well a
very famous famous end game
and the grand prix is being played it's
the first of three that will be played
to determine two challengers uh for the
uh next few day uh candidates tournament
so everyone gets a fair shot uh and uh
let's dive straight into it we're gonna
discuss a little bit more about the
tournament as it goes on but this is
classical chess so uh pl plenty of time
to think about the most let me just fix
the
uh the letter here uh on the little
robot forgot about that since the
previous video was a blitz game uh there
we go
uh alright so let's check it out uh
vincent with the white pieces opens with
a d4 uh we have d5 by dubois we have
c4c6 going for the slav defense
knight to f3 knight to f6 and e3 now and
dubo of course bishop f5 he wants to
develop his light square bishop before
closing the structure so knight c3 with
e6 the bishop is now nicely out of the
out of the cage and of course we go
after the bishop knight h4 so we want to
capture this bishop as black spent quite
a few moves developing it and now is our
chance to uh well eliminate it and
win the bishop pair so bishop g6 with
knight captures and h capture so now
white wins the bishop pair however black
has a fine pawn structure you can see
that all of the pawns in the center are
on light squares he has a dark square
bishop that will be very strong here and
he already has a semi-open file for his
rook so bishop d2 continuing development
knight b to d7 and now there are a
couple of moves that are very popular
here like rook c1 queen c2 g3 preparing
the fiance of the light square bishop uh
vincent goes for queen to b3 he goes
after the b7 pawn and dub of the pen
that defends it queen to c7 we have c
captures on d5 uh exchanging a pawn in
the center uh now saying that uh okay
now you can capture with the c pawn but
then i get the b5 square for my knight
so of course e captures on d5 is played
but now white is feeling very confident
to castle uh queen side so here we have
castle's queen side and there are a
couple of moves that um reached this
position but here the move do both plays
is a new one and he goes for a5 and
we're gonna discuss this position a
little bit more uh because it's super
interesting
uh for example if you start the attack
right away with c5 and uh why wouldn't
you the the king is on c1 uh then we see
knight captures on the five knight
characters queen captures and you get
the capture on d4 with a check uh but
it's not all that impressive after king
the b1 uh your your king is in the
center of the board and those bishops
are really really uh
ready to come and get you and especially
if something like the captures on e3
we're just going to play bishop a5
attack the queen and once the queen
moves because you also have to keep an
eye on the knight the queen and rook
battery
is going for that d7 square so after
queen c6 bishop to b5 you can even trade
queens here and you are still completely
winning captures captures there is no
way to save the knight uh it's a game
over the rook d8 is impossible because
the bishop covers this square so
it seems like black can launch an attack
right away that is not the case so you
could try something like bishop to e7
maybe just continue development or you
could try rook captures on h2 because
why wouldn't you now the problem is this
loses on the spot it's a
very sharp position a rook captures
queen captures and now queen characters
on b7 attacks the rook rook the b8
attacking the queen for example now
queen captures on c6 and this is just
disgusting for black that king in the
center of the board while black doesn't
really have an attack and you didn't
even win a pawn so that's why after all
of this uh is considered doom of plays
a5 this is a new move so as of movie 11
we have a completely new game uh we have
queen to c2 now you don't want your
queen here when that pawn starts
marching forward and now only now comes
rook captures an h2
again you could start with c5 but
you're not really attacking anything
there's a knight queen and king now on
the c file so it's not as dangerous so
instead rook captures an h2 now now this
can be played it is in fact the best
move rook captures we have queen
captures an h2 and now just a nice calm
a3 uh waiting to see what dubo will do
and now again a very very sharp position
uh we could try with uh with b5 right
away because i know you guys really want
to play this you want to play b5 b4 and
win the game with black however that's
not uh
how chess works white will play e4 and
now after b4 there's even e5 and now
look at this b captures on c3 we're just
gonna play queen captures on c3 and now
your knight is hanging but also queen
captures on c6 is very dangerous and now
let's say knight d4 you save your piece
queen captures on c6 we're going to play
rogue b8 now comes bishop to b5 and how
do you stop queen characters on d7
there's no good way to do this the
knight cannot go back to defend uh the
rook can't
really help with with this if you play
something like rook to d8 then bishop
captures on a5 and black completely
falls apart
and other than this you really don't
have a move so your best idea would be
something like rook captures on b5 and
then we will capture on b5 and even if
black trades further knight captures
here we can play queen captures on the
e5 and now trap the knight the knight
has no escape square well we're guarding
the g2 pawn so we don't allow queen
captures here and now after something
like bishop p7 we're gonna play king
captures on d2 and uh you have a much
much better position it's a rook against
the knight and bishop but
white is much stronger he has a
beautiful center here uh he can very
easily create a pass pawn here and that
rook can very easily infiltrate black's
position so white would be much better
here so instead we have bishop to e7
first a couple of safety moves first
king to b1 and now knight to b6 the
knight is now coming to c4
we have f3 controlling that knight on f6
also e4 is an idea in the future and now
knight to c4 a very nice attacker here
you can see that already some sacrifices
might be
incoming like bishop characters b
captures knight captures can pick up the
queen
but
it's very easily prevented oh you could
also capture the knight if bishop
captures on c4d captures uh now bishop
e1 let's say you defend the pawn here
now duboff can strike with b5 but now
it's very very dangerous and black's
attack is is happening so instead of
just a nice calm bishop the c1 and now
we have b5 and now b5 is definitely a
good push here so uh the best way to
counter attack uh
well when you're attacked on the queen
side is the counter attack in the center
so vincent pushes e4 this is what he
prepared
and now
again a really really interesting
position where uh double played b4 and
uh who wouldn't i mean it's such a nice
move to play but the b4
really weakens black's position and
that's one of the very few cases where
b4 is not great
to play uh the real move here is
something like rook to b8 or rook the c8
with extremely complicated play now but
obviously b4 was uh it was a miss by
double uh the idea is that after e5 and
knight d7 there's this e6 move and now
after knight to f8 you can either
capture on f7 but it doesn't really
bring you all that much so probably
bishop captures on c4 b captures and now
even this knight captures on d5 this
would be white's plan c captures queen
to a4 check king to d8 and now e
captures on f7 with the idea of queen to
e8 very dangerous then we want to pick
up the bishop so queen has to go back to
help defend the bishop now queen e8
czech king the c7
uh and now a nice calm rook to e1 you
don't care about rook captures queen
because the pawn will just bring another
queen into the game so bishop h4 we're
gonna save our bishop and now rookie two
we're gonna move the rook out out of
harm's way for example queen c6 we offer
a queen trade uh end of the game uh
continues but uh it's a really really uh
complicated position however something
like this would be best for black
however dubois played b4 and now
he allows this very tricky queen to a4
move and now okay you can capture the
knight but we're gonna play queen
captures in c6 and this is also a line
worth exploring uh it's an extremely
complicated game so we're gonna show it
uh there are many many cool lines here
for example king f8 we can give up the
rook and now after knight to the e8 you
can play b captures in c3 now knight
captures an a3 with check as the bishop
defends the knight the bishop captures
for example bishop captures and now it
looks like you've done some damage but
there's no way for the queen to actually
join the action if you could get the
queen here then it'd be great but it's
on h2 so that's not happening so white
has all the time in the world to you
know just win the game so instead after
queen a4 we have rooked the c8 now by do
both defending the pawn and now uh
vincent played a captures on b4 uh and
this was the moment probably uh where
vincent could have a gun gone in for the
kill with um with a move like uh for
example yeah instead of a capture some
before knight captures on d5 it's a very
interesting idea point being that after
characters and captures uh how do you
continue this with black uh black has
this knight to b6 move attacking the
queen and the pawn here and now we're
gonna capture on a five captures on d5
and now a4 this way white creates a pass
pawn and it's uh
better for white but still after a move
like b3 it's a very very double edged uh
i'm sure do would not mind playing this
so it's it's hard to say whether this is
going for the win uh or or you know
maybe to your doom but it was in the
position but okay a captures on b4 was
played but now comes bishop captures on
b4 and now it's a little bit different
uh the same idea no longer works because
the bishop guards the a5 pawn for
example knight captures knight captures
e captures uh we don't even have to play
this we can play bishop captures on c4
uh because it doesn't really matter if
pawn captures um
the the bishop now guards the a5 pawn so
now we would see knight b6 attacking
bishop and queen and only after the
queen moves something like captures
captures and queen captures on g2 it's
perfectly fine so after bishop captures
on b4 we have knight to a2 now attacking
the bishop here and dubo just moves it
back bishop to e7 now comes the bishop
captures on c4 d captures and now again
maybe a position where vincent could
have seized the the momentum uh he
played the d5 but uh it's uh well uh the
possession demands a rook d2 but it's
such a weird move to play you block your
bishop okay you guard the g2 pawn and
now you are getting ready to play rook
to c2 and then for example the game
might continue queen to c7 as you want
to keep an eye on your pawn here queen
captures on c4 and after 97 rook c2 now
we wanted this battery on the c file and
now white isn't uh just clearly clearly
better
so after d captures on c4 uh vinson
played d5 and then now comes uh king to
f8 now it's a good time to capture the
pawn on g2 double first on pins uh he's
very tired of this pin uh and now queen
captures on c4 we have queen back to c7
uh and now d captures in c6 we have
queen captures on c6 and now we have a
queen trade captures captures and now
bishop to d2 so now the material is
completely equal uh bishop knight and
rook against the bishop knight and rook
and the bishops are of the same color
however
white's position is still a little bit
better as uh he will have a an easier
time bringing the key into the game and
also he does not have double pawns dubo
has a double g pawn so a little
advantage but you know not not
negligible so rook to a6 uh defending
the pawn and of course putting the rook
behind your pawn it's still not a pass
pawn but you never know so knight c1
we're going after that pawn we have king
the e8 and the bishop to c3 now so the
knight can't move otherwise the g7 pawn
hangs so a4
uh now king a2 we have g5 uh and not
knight to d3 we have g4 trying to mess
up white's pawn structure knight to b
for now attacking the rook and here do
both trades we have captures captures
and now g captures an f3 we have g
captures and knight to d7 so the now got
rid of his doubled pawn and now the
position is uh well very much equal we
have f4
rook to c6 and now bishop to c3 going
after the g7 pawn so knight to c5 asking
white are you maybe interested in that
very nice pawn on g7
but then i'm capturing the e4 pawn so
rook d4 now we have uh
we defend this and also put more
pressure on the a4 pawn if the knight
moves and now knight to e6 forcing a
trade the a4 pawn for the f4 pawn so
rook captures on a4 and now knight
captures on f4 and now okay material is
still equal but bishop captures on g7
and now vincent is up a pawn so here uh
we have f6 uh trying to maybe maybe trap
this bishop somehow but it's very easily
easy to
get out bishop h6 we have knight to d3
uh and now rook to d4 attacking the
knight we have rook to a6 check king to
b1 and now knight captures on b2 here
dubo realized that he is down upon and
that the easiest way to end this game is
to just uh give up the knight for uh for
the two remaining pawns uh and go into a
well-known theoretical draw yeah it's a
it's a well-known theoretical draw but
it's uh well easily said then drawn uh
so here knight captures on b2 king
captures and now f5 that's why the
bishop on h6 is not safe now we are just
exchanging the pawn because the bishop
has to move so bishop to d2 and now f
captures on e4 rook captures on e4 and
we get this position the black king is
in check but we have a rook and bishop
against the rook
now uh we've done some videos on this on
this topic
and as the story goes um this is a a
draw in theory although there are uh you
know uh if you consider table bases uh
the the computers have sold this for us
over some
between 40 and 41 of these positions are
are winnable uh for the side with the
bishop but uh in uh yeah in truth it's
more like four percent because those uh
uh other 36 percent are very unnatural
positions that would not arise in in a
normal chess game between two very
strong grandmasters uh so it's not easy
to win this although it's possible for
example uh grand master keith arkell had
the disposition 18 times in a game
not this exact same position but bishop
and rook against the rook and he won it
18 times out of 18.
so that's uh one one way to look at it
and paul benko uh can uh
consider this uh ending the so-called
headache ending and hence the title so
here came to d7 uh we're gonna try and
checkmate the the black king somehow
king to b3 and now rook to a1 uh we have
king to c4 we're gonna have to try and
box in the black king because you either
win this by checkmating the black king
right away or by winning the rook first
and then checkmating in the black king
there's no other way
so rook to a6 and now bishop to b4 so
now we're going to try
to box the king in further we have rook
to e6 now comes rook to h4 king to c6
and now bishop to c5 so not taking away
squares from the black king we have rook
to g6 now comes bishop d4 we have rooked
the e6 and now rook to h1 so how can
white make progress here rook to g6 and
now rook to a1 we are hoping for rook a6
check to pick up the rook so rook to g2
now comes to rook a6 check we win a few
more squares king d7 now comes king to
d5 and now comes the critical move uh
that you you should remember if you play
this uh rook to d2 we have to pin the
bishop pinning the bishop allows you to
successfully defend this
game
because now after rook to a7 check uh
king moves and it's very easy to make a
mistake here here king the d8 or king
the e8 is fine but if you play king to
c8 just to give you an example now of
how tricky this endgame is even though
you've played the correct move and
pinned the bishop it's actually a forced
checkmate in 18 moves uh to give you uh
an example king the c6 now we're
threatening checkmate uh we don't care
about our bishop so rook c2 check now
we're gonna play bishop c5 we're still
threatening checkmate so rugby two are
ready to meet rook to a8 with rook to b8
now we play rook to h7 now we threaten
this checkmate so rook to d2 now getting
ready to block the rook or rooks check
with rook to d8 now comes rook to g7 we
waste the move and now as a black what
do you play so black plays rook to d1 he
cannot remain on the second rank uh rook
the a7 again threatening checkmate and
now after rook to b1 we play bishop to
a3 that's why we wanted the rook on the
first rank now rook the c1 is no longer
an option so what can you play rook to
b3 you have to keep an eye on that b8
square otherwise rook to a8 this game
over and now we play bishop to d6 now
again uh this check and if rogue blocks
we're just gonna capture it with
checkmate so here rook to c3 check
bishop to c5 now and now rook to b3
again we are ready to meet a check with
rook to b8 but now comes rook the c7
check king to d8 and rook to f7 and
there is no stopping checkmate now it
doesn't matter what you play rook to f8
will be checkmate that's uh that's just
it and of course the rook to e3 is
impossible as the bishop covers the e3
square so that's how uh how tricky it is
to play this so uh you you can't play
king c8 of course dubois played king to
d8 and now we uh of course vincent will
try everything he has 50 moves um after
the last piece has been captured and
after the last pawn has been moved and
he will try his best so king c5 we have
king e8 rook to a1 king d7 king d5 we
have rook to d3 rook to g1 rook d2 rook
h1 king c7 rook h7 check and now again
king to d8 we're gonna see king e5 uh
king the c8 and the bishop to c5 so of
course he's hoping for a mistake dubo
offers a rook trade rook h8 king c7
bishop d4 this is all now
uh very standard stuff because if you
know that
the the few tricks that are needed
you will be able to defend but like i
said uh even grandmasters miss out on
this but in classical chess okay when
you have plenty of time it's uh a little
bit easier to defend so king c6 rook h6
checking b5 king e4 rook e7 check now
king to d3 rook b7 we have rookie 6 rook
b8 uh rook to d6 rook b7 king to e4
trying a little bit of everything rook
h7 rogue b6 check now king c4 and now
rook c6 king b5 back rook c5 checking
before rook the c8 and now king to b5
with bishop e5 rookie for chuck king to
d5 now rook h5 rook to b8 chuck king a5
and king to d4
we have king a6 bishop to c7 rook to b5
and rook to g8 so no easy way to to do
this king b7 now comes king to c for
rook f5 a bishop g3 and now king to c6
and here we have king to d4 and he was
in this position on move 85 that they
agreed to a draw uh i don't believe
they've met that the 50 move rule was
met i just think that uh yeah it wasn't
met they just agreed to a draw so of
course you will always try but then your
opponent plays quickly he shows you that
he knows very well how to defend this
confidently and then of course there
will be no point in continuing but if
you don't know what you're doing
like uh you know keith arkell managed to
win 18 out of 18 games that he had um
such a position and then
it could be a problem
uh so yeah very nicely done by both of
them maybe vincent had uh had a chance
if he played extremely sharp but then
again going extremely sharp against
dubois
does not end well for her for people so
it was a
well a fine a fine game and uh
well do both tried a little bit but it
it didn't um
it didn't work vincent played everything
perfectly and aside from that maybe one
move where he could have seized the
advantage uh everything else was was
immaculate
uh so that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it if you have a favorite one of
your own do share i'm uh probably gonna
gonna do arenan with it next so uh
prepare for that i would like to thank
nagarjuna ponogoti gm sucks rocks the
original scock-o-matic the evans gambit
for being winning and ken scott for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot to really appreciate it as usual you
can check to all my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
feed a grand prix uh until it ends and
of course checking up on your wonderful
suggestions uh so thank you all i will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day